Jake:呃是
Jake: Uh, yes.
Jake: 哈喽不用
Jake: Hello, no need.
Jake: 不用在这呆着就行
Jake: No need to stay here, just fine.
Jake: 你们就在一楼吧
Jake: You guys stay on the first floor.
Shure:  我去外面吧
Shure: I'll go outside then.
Jake:也行
Jake: That works too.
Alice: 一楼扫完了吗
Alice: Is the first floor swept?
Jake:扫完了
Jake: Yes, it's done.
Jake: 那个你可以
Jake: You can...
Jake: 反正反正
Jake: Anyway, anyway...
Jake: 我上去你们就可以到一楼
Jake: When I go up, you guys can stay on the first floor.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 可以的可以的都可以上
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, everyone can come up.
Jake:谁啊
Jake: Who's there?
Jake: 可以上可以上
Jake: You can come up, come up.
Jake: 上上上
Jake: Go, go, go!
Jake: 呃我上楼你把所有门都开开
Jake: Uh, I'm going upstairs. You open all the doors.
Choiszt:  呃我先把上边门都开开
Choiszt: Uh, I'll open all the doors upstairs first.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 然后下来叫我
Jake: Then come down and call me.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 从我后边走
Jake: Walk behind me.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 你到我后面去
Jake: Get behind me.
Jake: 你从后面绕
Jake: Go around from the back.
Choiszt:  我靠你这个速度太快了
Choiszt: Damn, you're too fast!
Choiszt:  那应该我不动然后你动
Choiszt: I should stay still and you move.
Jake: 我靠这是为什么
Jake: Damn, why is that?
Jake: 你躲到一楼去
Jake: Hide on the first floor.
Jake: 有门吗
Jake: Is there a door?
Jake: 啊你你你
Jake: Ah, you, you, you...
Jake: 先躲在一楼
Jake: Hide on the first floor first.
Jake: 我要回头
Jake: I need to turn back.
Jake: 马上
Jake: Right away.
Jake: 走走
Jake: 来吧
Jake:来吧
Jake: 好开吹吧
Tasha: 就我们仨
Jake: 都来了
Jake: 别门得关了
Jake: 不能坐着
Jake: 哈哈哈多少有点离谱
Jake: 进来吧进来吧
Jake: 哎开开了
Choiszt:  今天晚上GoPro还导吗
Jake: 导
Choiszt:  这次应该快
Jake:OK了
Jake: 希望如此吧
Jake: 这不要立flag
Jake: 真的
Jake: 我靠行行
Jake: 我靠这真的真的
Jake: 做梦时候就在想这个
Jake: I was dreaming about this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 主要是插电不方便
Jake: The main issue is that plugging it in is inconvenient.
Lucia: 啊我突然有点想把那个Pad吃了哦
Lucia: Ah, I suddenly feel like I could eat that Pad.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 不光想来点夜宵
Lucia: Not just a midnight snack.
Lucia: 甚至还想看看有别的什么能吃的
Lucia: I even want to see if there's anything else to eat.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 不是你那拍照不给我录啥意思
Jake: Why didn't you let me record your photo?
Jake: 对就聊聊就吹吹牛就拉倒
Jake: Yeah, just chatting and bragging, and that's it.
Jake: 啊不交换礼物
Jake: Ah, no gift exchange.
Jake: 明早交换礼物
Jake: We'll exchange gifts in the morning.
Jake: 什么派
Jake: What pie?
Lucia: 我还没吃
Lucia: I haven't eaten it yet.
Lucia: 我尝一口告诉你哦
Lucia: I'll take a bite and let you know.
Jake: 你还不知道什么派
Jake: You don't even know what pie it is?
Katrina:  显示电量太低
Katrina: The battery is too low.
Katrina:  但是一直在充
Katrina: But it's been charging.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 你给他充一会
Jake: Let it charge for a while.
Jake: 你也没电了
Jake: You're out of battery too.
Jake: 你没电了呀
Jake: You're out of battery, huh?
Jake: 你没电了
Jake: No power left.
Jake: 你连不上看不了
Jake: You can't connect, can't watch.
Lucia: no that's mine
Lucia: No, that's mine.
Lucia: 哈哈当然你可以用
Lucia: Haha, of course, you can use it.
Katrina:  这个味道变了吗
Katrina: Did the taste change?
Lucia: 没有昨天的吧这是
Lucia: No, it's from yesterday, right?
Lucia: 这么甜应该不容易坏
Lucia: It's so sweet, it shouldn't spoil easily.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这是这是
Jake: This is, this is...
Katrina:  西柚就是比橙汁兑着好
Katrina: Grapefruit is better mixed with orange juice.
Lucia: 橙汁适合加入那个龙舌兰
Lucia: Orange juice is good for adding to tequila.
Lucia: 好这个薛定谔的派是红豆味的
Lucia: Okay, this Schrödinger's pie is red bean flavored.
Jake: 红豆味哈哈红豆
Jake: Red bean flavor, haha, red bean.
Jake: 哦不好意思不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Jake: 他得冲到5%左右吧
Jake: It has to charge up to around 5%, right?
Jake: 10% 嗯
Jake: 10%, hmm.
Jake: 对就是
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Jake: 其实是一伙人进去围观
Jake: Actually, a group of people went in to watch.
Jake: 你邀请吗
Jake: Did you invite them?
Lucia: 啊我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: Ah, my glasses are on.
Jake: 哈哈哈执法执法记录仪执法记录仪
Jake: Hahaha, law enforcement recorder, law enforcement recorder.
Lucia: 我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: My glasses are on.
Lucia: 谨言慎行啊哈哈
Lucia: Be cautious with your words, haha.
Jake: 我们每个房间都要走一遍
Jake: We have to go through each room.
Shure:  好有经验好有经验什么鬼
Shure: So experienced, so experienced, what the heck.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  这到底是什么呀
Katrina: What exactly is this?
Nicous:  按的按
Nicous: Press it, press.
Nicous:  就是是一和7
Nicous: It's a one and seven.
Jake: 这是什么呃
Jake: What's this, uh?
Nicous:  这是什么
Nicous: What's this?
Nicous:  那这个一和7的
Nicous: So, this one and seven...
Nicous:  嗯这就是一个
Nicous: Hmm, this is one.
Lucia: 嗯这是地球吗
Lucia: Hmm, is this Earth?
Lucia: 有点像是吧
Lucia: Kind of looks like it, right?
Jake: 这是什么方向呢
Jake: What direction is this?
Jake: 澳大利亚
Jake: Australia.
Jake: 南极
Jake: Antarctica.
Lucia: 虽然比例有点不对
Lucia: 但他可以
Nicous:  卧槽
Jake: 这个是高级手段
Jake: 一个月能学会吗
Nicous: 我这不明天就肺癌
Jake: 是直接抽
Jake: 抽烟烟烟
Nicous:  你是人吗
Jake: 你直接吃了吧
Nicous: 我靠我他妈吃了都比抽健康
Nicous:  就是减少
Nicous:  我说你这也太抽象了拍我
Choiszt:  我以为是因为我看那个什么电视
Choiszt:  电影里拿张纸抽
Jake: 那抽的是哈哈哈
Jake: 手段有点
Jake: 啥玩意
Jake: 你在这秀
Jake: 哈哈不给看
Shure:  哎呀啊啊
Shure: Ahhhh!
Katrina:  好恶心啊
Katrina: That's so disgusting.
Nicous: 给你带来了快乐你开着呢
Nicous: Did it bring you joy?
Shure:  你觉得我们俩口音像吗
Shure: Do you think our accents are similar?
Jake: 不像
Jake: Not at all.
Shure: 但是但是我我那些同学听到我
Shure: But, but my classmates hear me...
:Jake:我知道我知道哈哈
Jake: I know, I know, haha.
Jake: 哎你也没电了
Jake: Oh, you're out of battery too.
Tasha: 我刚充上电了已经
Tasha: I just started charging it.
Jake: 好吧我们走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 我感觉凑不了凑不到人
Jake: I feel like we can't gather enough people.
Jake: 喝多了
Jake: Had too much to drink.
Jake: 意思一下
Jake: Just a little bit.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina:  哎这现在还不能拔是吧
Katrina: Hey, we can't unplug it yet, right?
Shure: what
Shure: What?
Lucia: 那根线上还写着我名字呢
Lucia: My name is even written on that cord.
Lucia: 好吧原来您也看过魔剑
Lucia: Oh, so you've watched "Magic Sword" too.
Jake: 开始了
Jake: It's starting.
Lucia: 我还害怕
Lucia: I'm still scared.
Lucia: 我今天讲那个关于咕噜的冷笑话
Lucia: Today I'm going to tell that joke about Gollum
Lucia: 没人听懂来着
Lucia: No one got it though
Katrina:  来吧来吧
Katrina: Go ahead, go ahead
Jake:来吧
Jake: Go ahead
Shure:  先先先介绍什么
Shure: First, first, first, introduce something
Jake: 你开了吗你
Jake: Did you start yet?
Katrina:  没开
Katrina: No, not yet
Shure: 好没开
Shure: Okay, not yet
Jake: 先先聊到克星啊
Jake: Let's first talk about the nemesis
Alice: 都要进来吗
Alice: Is everyone coming in?
Jake: 对毕竟你收拾过了吧
Jake: Yeah, since you cleaned up, right?
Alice: 啊我的想法就是
Alice: Ah, my idea is...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 因为这个房间比较小
Alice: Since this room is quite small
Alice: 然后这个白色占的面积特别大
Alice: And the white color takes up a lot of space
Alice: 我就打算买一个床单
Alice: I plan to buy a bedsheet
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah
Alice: 然后就整体上就看起来被改造过了
Alice: So overall it will look remodeled
Alice: 然后搞一个桌布
Alice: And then get a tablecloth
Alice: 然后这个上面放一个微型的小的
Alice: And put a tiny miniature landscape on it
Alice: 小的景观
Alice: A small landscape
Alice: 微型景观
Alice: A miniature landscape
Alice: 然后有海藻球
Alice: With a seaweed ball
Alice: 然后买一个杯垫
Alice: And then buy a coaster
Alice: 然后上面放一个桂花味的香薰
Alice: And put an osmanthus scented candle on it
Alice: 整体就是一个跟这个米黄色搭相近的
Alice: Overall it will be a color that matches the beige, like a creamy green
Alice: 一个奶绿色吧
Alice: Something like that
Alice: 大概就是这样
Alice: That's about it
Jake: 这叫啥主题呢
Jake: What's the theme called?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay
Jake: 可心主题
Jake: Cozy theme
Jake: 初春初春
Jake: Early spring, early spring
Jake: make sense
Jake: Makes sense
Jake: 好make sense
Jake: Alright, makes sense
Jake: 来看你怎么吹牛逼
Jake: Let's see how you boast
Jake: 忘记他不能吹你的是吧那我
Jake: Forgot he can't boast about you, right, then I...
Jake: 好那我们先上楼吧
Jake: Alright, let's go upstairs first
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Jake: 就赛博主题
Jake: Just a cyber theme
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经装修好了
Lucia: Hahaha, it's already decorated
Jake: 完工完工状态
Jake: Finished, all done.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's it going?
Tasha: 进度100%
Tasha: Progress 100%.
Jake: 还是蓝色
Jake: Still blue.
Jake: 地球地球赛博
Jake: Earth, earth, cyber.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 蓝白相间
Lucia: Blue and white.
Jake: 对停电一小时电脑都开着
Jake: Yeah, even with an hour of power outage, the computers are all on.
Lucia: 哦对这是科幻主题吧
Lucia: Oh right, this is a sci-fi theme, right?
Katrina:  这呀呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Katrina: This, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  我的
Katrina: Mine.
Katrina:  我打算这不是三勾子吗
Katrina: I plan, isn’t this three hooks?
Katrina:  他们到了吗
Katrina: Have they arrived?
Jake: 嚯还有三个钩子
Jake: Wow, there are three hooks.
Katrina:  嗯叫什么卷帘画
Katrina: Yeah, it’s called a scroll painting.
Katrina:  就是那种我我的主题
Katrina: It’s like, my theme.
Katrina:  叫动物party
Katrina: It's called Animal Party.
Jake: 叫什么动物派对
Jake: What’s it called, Animal Party?
Katrina: 动物派对
Katrina: Animal Party.
Jake: 动物派对动物partyOK
Jake: Animal Party, Animal Party, okay.
Katrina:  这边全都是那种画就是那种偏春天
Katrina: Over here, it’s all paintings, like spring-themed.
Katrina:  然后动物的
Katrina: And animals.
Katrina:  然后这边也搞一个那个画
Katrina: And over here, we’ll put another painting.
Katrina:  就是买那个美纹纸贴一个大的那个
Katrina: Just buy that masking tape and stick a big one.
Katrina:  呃海报一样的
Katrina: Like a poster.
Katrina:  然后这边挂一个那个壁画
Katrina: And hang a mural over here.
Katrina:  然后这边摆几个小娃娃
Katrina: Then place a few dolls here.
Katrina:  就是全部是动物的那种
Katrina: All of them are animal-themed.
Katrina:  然后地上搞一个那个地毯
Katrina: And put a rug on the floor.
Katrina:  就是那种苔藓的那种形状的
Katrina: Like in the shape of moss.
Katrina:  然后那那那边还有一部分的区域
Katrina: And then that area over there.
Katrina:  打算就放我的那个花
Katrina: I plan to put my flowers.
Katrina:  然后还有一个那个香薰小夜灯
Katrina: And also a small scented night light.
Katrina:  就是那香薰既能香
Katrina: The scent can be fragrant.
Katrina:  又有那个夜灯的功能
Katrina: And also has the night light function.
Katrina:  然后床上放一个松
Katrina: And on the bed, put a pine.
Katrina:  嗯那个松树的叫什么松树
Katrina: Uh, what’s it called, a pine.
Katrina:  哈哈松树的那个玩偶
Katrina: Haha, a pine tree doll.
Katrina:  抱枕然后再放一只小狐狸的那个玩偶
Katrina: A pillow, then add a little fox doll.
Katrina:  然后差不多就是这样
Katrina: And that's pretty much it.
Katrina:  对就是全部都是动物的元素
Katrina: Yes, it's all animal-themed.
Katrina:  然后就是整体是绿色的基调
Katrina: And the overall tone is green.
Katrina:  然后都买好了
Katrina: And we've bought everything.
Jake: 哦挺好嗯差不多5,000块钱
Jake: Oh, that's nice. About 5,000 yuan.
Jake: 好挺好哈哈哈没有没有没有
Jake: Good, that's good. Haha, no, no, no.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 我我我我也很喜欢这个房间
Jake: I really like this room too.
Jake: 因为这是我房间原来的样子
Jake: Because this is how my room used to look.
Jake: 现在变成了那个样子
Jake: Now it looks like this.
Tasha: 房间我想要做成一个色彩
Tasha: I want the room to have a colorful look.
Tasha: 多巴胺的那种
Tasha: Like a dopamine kind of vibe.
Tasha: 嗯然后我决定再多用一些蓝色
Tasha: And then I decided to use more blue.
Jake: 你还在充电是吧
Jake: You're still charging, right?
Tasha: 蓝色和粉色的元素
Tasha: Blue and pink elements.
Tasha: 嗯嗯弄个地毯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, and get a rug.
Tasha: 换个床单
Tasha: Change the bed sheets.
Tasha: 再搞一点装饰画
Tasha: And add some decorative paintings.
Tasha: 然后那个窗户
Tasha: And for the window,
Tasha: 我想把它那个贴那种
Tasha: I want to put one of those...
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Like...
Tasha: 相当于是打开窗户的一个景色的那种
Tasha: It's like having a scenic view when you open the window.
Tasha: 窗布嗯嗯
Tasha: Curtains, yeah.
Lucia: 这样子他就会有那种夏天的感觉
Lucia: That way it'll have a summer feel.
Jake: 叫什么来着
Jake: What's it called again?
Katrina:  你的主题
Katrina: Your theme.
Tasha: 多巴胺多巴胺
Tasha: Dopamine, dopamine.
Jake:多巴胺
Jake: Dopamine.
Lucia: 是这个主题吗
Lucia: Is that the theme?
Lucia: 我记得对吧
Lucia: I remember, right?
Jake: 到路亚了
Jake: It's up to you.
Lucia: 哎呀我这个牛的草稿还没有打好
Lucia: Oh no, I haven't even finished the draft for the cow yet.
Lucia: 大家就凑合着听一听
Lucia: Everyone just bear with me.
Lucia: 就是我这个房间
Lucia: So, this room,
Lucia: 他很不巧就没有挂钩
Lucia: Unfortunately, doesn't have hooks.
Lucia: 然后这个桌子
Lucia: And this table...
Jake:你后面其实有个挂钩
Jake: Actually, there's a hook behind you.
Jake: 但是啥也不是
Jake: But it's not really useful.
Lucia: 哦那个后面啊
Lucia: Oh, back there?
Jake:对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 就是姑且认为是他没有吧
Lucia: I guess we can assume he doesn't have it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 所以我的想法是
Lucia: So, my idea is...
Lucia: 我可能把这个搬出去
Lucia: I might move this out.
Lucia: 然后在这里放一个小桌子
Lucia: And then put a small table here.
Lucia: 然后可以给上面盖一个桌布
Lucia: And then cover it with a tablecloth.
Lucia: 然后我现在想的大概是蓝白这种主题
Lucia: Right now, I'm thinking of a blue and white theme.
Lucia: 色调就是搞一个偏地中海这种风格
Lucia: The color scheme would be kind of Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 或者说面朝大海
Lucia: Or maybe something like "facing the sea."
Lucia: 春暖花开这样
Lucia: "Spring blossoms."
Lucia: 对然后这边的话
Lucia: Yeah, and over here...
Lucia: 到时候可能还要
Lucia: I might need to...
Lucia: 我明天还要再看一下格局
Lucia: I need to check the layout again tomorrow.
Lucia: 如果合适可能想放一个照片墙
Lucia: If it fits, I might want to put up a photo wall.
Lucia: 然后给上面挂一些渔网啊
Lucia: And then hang some fishing nets or...
Lucia: 或者贝壳这样的东西
Lucia: Shells on it.
Lucia: 然后也可以装饰一些照片
Lucia: And we could also decorate with some photos.
Lucia: 或者小的那种照贴画
Lucia: Or little photo stickers.
Lucia: 明信片
Lucia: Postcards.
Lucia: 嗯然后床单的话
Lucia: Hmm, and for the bed sheets...
Lucia: 就是因为这个床
Lucia: It's because of this bed.
Lucia: 他占的面积实在是很大
Lucia: It takes up a lot of space.
Lucia: 所以呃
Lucia: So, um...
Lucia: 我还在想是买一个就是蓝色的
Lucia: I was thinking of buying a blue one.
Lucia: 就是他的色调和明度
Lucia: You know, one that matches the room's color and brightness.
Lucia: 这些都跟房间还比较符合的床单呢
Lucia: Or maybe buy two small cushions.
Lucia: 还是买两个就是小抱枕
Lucia: Like, um...
Lucia: 就是呃
Lucia: Maybe a shark
Lucia: 比如说像鲨鱼啊
Lucia: Or some other sea creature.
Lucia: 或者之类的这种海洋生物
Lucia: And that's about it.
Lucia: 嗯然后就没有什么了
Lucia: The curtain color can't really be changed.
Lucia: 这个窗帘的颜色感觉没有办法改变
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 窗户挺大
Jake: The window is pretty big.
Jake: 窗户外面是啥
Jake: What's outside the window?
Lucia: 窗户外面打开的话就就是对面的房子
Lucia: When you open the window, it's just the house across the street.
Lucia: 对然后我还有一个想法是
Lucia: Yeah, and I was thinking of
Lucia: 可能会买一个小夜灯
Lucia: Maybe getting a small night light.
Lucia: 然后就是呃
Lucia: 如果说把灯关上
Lucia: What if we turn off the lights...
Lucia: 然后打开它的话
Lucia: Then if you turn it on
Lucia: 就能有一种波光粼粼的效果啊
Lucia: You'll get this kind of sparkling effect.
Lucia: 对对对是的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 就很符合大海这个主题
Lucia: It fits the ocean theme perfectly.
Jake: OK地中海主题
Jake: Okay, Mediterranean theme.
Lucia: 哈哈希望顺利
Lucia: Haha, hope it goes well.
Jake: 开灯了吗
Jake: Did you turn on the lights?
Jake: 你开电了吗
Jake: Did you turn on the power?
Jake: 你多少
Jake: What's your percentage?
Jake: 百分之几啊
Jake: How many percent?
Shure:  我一直显示0%
Shure: It still shows 0%.
Jake: 你充上了吗
Jake: Are you charging it?
Shure:  我我我确实是充上了
Shure: Yes, yes, I really did charge it.
Jake: 你好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 来吧就就我们
Jake: Come on, just us.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 嗯挺干净
Jake: Hmm, pretty clean.
Jake: 我刚刚扫的时候
Jake: When I was sweeping earlier
Jake: 就觉得你这个地方素材挺多
Jake: I noticed you have a lot of materials here.
Katrina:  哦你把花也买上去了
Katrina: Oh, you even bought the flowers.
Jake: 哎你剪过吗这个花
Jake: Hey, did you trim these flowers?
Shure:  没有
Shure: No.
Shure:  我觉得他本来样子就是最完美的
Shure: I think they look perfect as they are.
Shure:  就是雨轩同月敞的样子
Shure: Just like Yu Xuan Tong Yue's style.
Katrina:  原生态原生态
Katrina: Natural, natural.
Katrina:  哎他这自带这种东西啊
Katrina: Hey, it comes with this stuff?
Jake: 对是哦
Jake: Yeah, it does.
Shure:  我这个房间自带一些隔断
Shure: My room comes with some partitions.
Katrina:  那他买点那个东西装摆上面就好了
Katrina: Then just buy some decorations for it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure:  我也我也不知道要摆些什么
Shure: I don't even know what to place here.
Shure:  就是哎
Shure: Just, eh...
Shure:  我我我我我杂物就堆在这里了然后那个
Shure: I just pile up my stuff here, and then...
Jake: 介绍挺好
Jake: Good introduction.
Shure:  需要充电的设备每天就在这啪啪的
Shure: The devices that need charging are all here every day.
Shure:  然后然后充在这里
Shure: And then I charge them here.
Jake: 代表什么呀
Jake: What does that represent?
Shure:  代表着
Shure: It represents...
Shure:  人生需要一些charging
Shure: Life needs some charging.
Katrina:  特别像老师讲课哈哈哈
Katrina: It's like a teacher giving a lesson, haha.
Lucia: 具有实用价值
Lucia: It's really practical.
Shure:  对非常具有实用价值
Shure: Yes, it's very practical.
Shure:  然后如果
Shure: And if
Shure:  如果哪位同学想过来住一住的话
Shure: If any student wants to come and stay, that's definitely not a problem.
Shure:  这个也是肯定是不介意的
Shure: They are absolutely welcome.
Lucia: 然后而且有这么多枕头
Lucia: And there are so many pillows.
Lucia: 就是大家想枕头大战也是可以的
Lucia: So if anyone wants a pillow fight, that's possible too.
Shure: 12345最多可以五个人一起
Shure: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, up to five people can join in.
Katrina:  赶紧走哈哈哈
Katrina: Hurry up, let's go, hahaha.
Katrina:  好可怕这个人
Katrina: This person is so scary.
Jake: 这个这个得团队讨论一下
Jake: This needs to be discussed by the team.
Jake: 要不要毙掉
Jake: Whether to scrap it or not.
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake: 给我们增加了一些工作量挺好
Jake: It added some work for us, that's good.
Jake: 好那我们今天就这样明早见
Jake: Alright, that's it for today. See you tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 下班
Katrina: End of work.
Jake: 下班下班下班
Jake: End of work, end of work.
Shure:  拜拜拜拜
Shure: Bye bye, bye bye.
Jake: 放这吧
Jake: Leave it here.
Katrina:  再见了赛博人生
Katrina: Goodbye, cyber life.
Jake: 明天早上
Jake: Tomorrow morning,
Jake: 呃大家把礼物准备一下
Jake: Uh, everyone prepare your gifts.
Jake: 然后有一个沙雕小游戏
Jake: And there will be a fun little game.
Katrina:  沙雕小游戏
Katrina: A fun little game?
Jake: 对对就是来规定一下顺
Jake: Yes, to decide the order.
Jake: 序吧谁
Jake: The order of who
Jake: 谁先选这个礼物
Jake: Who picks the gift first.
Jake: 哎怎么说就是
Jake: How should I put it...
Jake: 谁先展示并且送给谁
Jake: Who presents and gives it to whom.
Jake: 还是怎么送
Jake: Or how to give it.
Lucia: 送到一堆然后大家都不知道这是谁的
Lucia: Pile them up and no one knows whose is whose.
Lucia: 然后就是确定某个顺序
Lucia: And then decide on an order.
Lucia: 然后都可以挑一个
Lucia: And everyone can pick one.
Lucia: 觉得圣诞节圣诞树底下堆礼物那种
Lucia: Like a Christmas tree with presents underneath.
Jake: 好吧那就没有游戏了
Jake: Okay, then no game.
Jake:挺好就这样
Jake: That's good, let's do that.
Lucia: 需要一个游戏来确定大家挑顺序吗
Lucia: Do we need a game to decide the order?
Jake:呃好那合理那合理太合理了好就这样
Jake: Uh, alright, that's reasonable. Very reasonable. Let's do that.